>> Reggie: WE SAW IT IN THE
CLOSEOUT GAME VERSUS THE LAKERS
IN GAME SIX, AND IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER OF GAME ONE.
>> Kevin: PORTER, AND THERE IS A
SHOT FROM 17, AND FINALLY
GETTING ONE TO DROP.
HE IS 1 OF 8.
>> Reggie: SOMETIMES THAT IS ALL
IT TAKES.
SEE THE BALL GO THROUGH THE RIM.
MAYBE THAT CAN GET PORTER JR.
GOING OFFENSIVELY HERE, BECAUSE
THEY NEED THE SECONDARY SCORER
FOR THE NUGGET TEAM.
>> Kevin: AND FOLLOWING AND GET
IT, AND COUNT IT.
PORTER IS WATCHING ON THE
DISTANCE AND RIVERS WAS LEANING
IN ON THE SWITCH AND BOOKER
DRAINS IT.
>> Reggie: THIS YOUNG MAN HAS
ZERO FEAR.
I AM TELLING YOU THAT THIS IS
VERY REMINISCENT OF HIS
CHILDHOOD IDOL KOBE BRYANT, AND
HOW MANY TIMES DID WE SEE KOBE
MAKE A MOVE LIKE THAT, PUMP
FAKE, JAB STEP, AND THE DEFENDER
CROWDS YOU AND YOU RAISE UP WITH
CONTACT AND KNOCK DOWN THE